all right guys you might be having to
the same issues
at least in my drops because this smoke
does really burn your eyes a little bit
we've got a little haze out there
a little layer of it but we'll get some
afternoon breezes should lift it out a
little bit better again
it's not as bad as it was on saturday
saturday's air was
awful it was brown and yucky we were
getting so many great
pictures and videos but finally it got
so much better yesterday
we've got a lot of 80s around the valley
this morning centennial hills you're at
77
79 at aliante 84 out at red rock we will
get those southwest breezes this
afternoon
and that should help that smoky haze
retreat a little bit more
88 in laughlin 84 in boulder city this
morning
71 up at indian springs and param at 80
degrees so we're going to start off hot
and hazy to get back to school today
slight chances for thunderstorms a
little push the monsoon
midweek and then again on the weekend
when we're not having the monsoon
moisture we're going to have the heat
and again that smoke is being pulled
over into nevada it's all coming
from the wildfires the two biggest the
dixie and the tamarack fires over in
california
107 for our first day of back to school
week afternoon breezes could get up to
about 25 miles per hour
and again tomorrow we get a little more
surge of monsoon moisture just a slight
chance of thunderstorms in the afternoon
for the valley
better chance up in the mountains and
down in southern clark county around
laughlin over to bullhead city
and then again back on the weekend so
it's a fairly hot week for the kids to
get back to school
make sure they got plenty of water in
the backpacks and wearing the sunscreen